hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and calm and today we're gonna
talk about digoxin and this video is
part of an in clicks review series over
pharmacology and as always after you
watch this YouTube video you can access
the free quiz that will test you on this
medication so let's get started
when studying these drugs for exams or
even administering them to a patient you
always want to make sure that you are
familiar with the drug so to help
yourself do that anytime you come across
a drug name you want to ask yourself the
following five questions number one
what's the name of the drug specifically
that family name what drug category does
this drug fall into because that's going
to tell you a lot about how that drug
works next you want to ask yourself what
is this drug used for and that's going
to tell you why you're giving this
medication to the patient they have some
type of condition that the physician
feels like the patient would benefit
from this drug then you want to ask
yourself what are your responsibilities
as a nurse when dealing with this drug
what are you watching for monitoring for
then you want to ask yourself what are
those side effects the common side
effects that may be seen with this drug
and then lastly you want to ask yourself
those education pieces that you need to
provide to that patient so if they do go
home on this drug they will know how to
take it properly so to help us remember
all those questions let's remember the
word nurse because whenever we're
administering medications we have to
think as a nurse so first let's talk
about the name so we're dealing with the
drug digoxin and this drug is part of
the cardiac glycoside family and these
drugs help the heart pump more
efficiently by inhibiting the normal
function of the sodium and potassium
pump now this pump is found on the cell
membrane of our cells that make up our
muscle fibers and muscle fibers play a
huge role in how strong your heart is
able to contract so if we alter that
pump we're going to alter the
contractility of this
heart muscle now another thing the
dachshund does is it alters how fast or
how slow your heart beat so it's going
to alter the rate and it can alter how
fast these impulses are sent through the
electrical conduction system of the
heart
now there's three things I just
described are the inner trophic Crona
trophic and drama trophic actions of the
heart and digoxin either effects that in
a positive or negative way so let's talk
about how it affects the heart and you
want to remember these actions because
tests love to ask about that when
referring to digoxin
so digoxin causes a positive inotropic
effect on the heart and what this means
is that it causes the heart to squeeze
or contract harder so it increases
cardiac contractility which in the end
is going to increase stroke volume
another thing it does is it has a
negative chrono trophic effect on the
heart which causes the heart to be at a
slower rate it also causes a negative
drama trophic effect which is going to
cause impulses to be sent slower through
the AV node now when we take all these
actions and combine them together what's
the result for our patient's heart the
heart is gonna squeeze more blood out so
more blood is going to leave the heart
so whenever we're doing that we're
increasing stroke volume and stroke
volume is the mail of blood that is
leaving this ventricle with each beat
and when we increase that we're going to
increase cardiac output we want good
cardiac output because if we don't have
a high enough cardiac output your organs
aren't being perfused and the patient
can die and remember cardiac output is
calculated by taking the heart rate
times the stroke volume and stroke
volume one of the big things that affect
stroke volume was contractility and
digoxin increases contractility so we
will get increased cardiac output now
let's talk about what it's used for
digoxin is used to treat heart failure
cardiogenic shock or dysrhythmias like
atrial fibrillation or
a flutter and why we would want to throw
on digoxin in some of these patients is
because with these conditions there's
issues with the heart pumping and
emptying correctly either like with
heart failure or cardiogenic shock
there's failure of this heart as a pump
those muscle fibers aren't contracting
like a lot of times in my cardio
infarction happens these cells die that
play a role in how our heart contracts
so the heart just doesn't pump very well
or the electrical conduction system like
an afib a flutter is just discharging
impulses way too fast and it's altering
how the heart is able to empty now let's
talk about responsibilities what's our
responsibility as the nurse well we did
we really want to monitor for toxicity
because patients can become toxic with
this drug so what are those early signs
and symptoms that hey your patient may
be experiencing digoxin toxicity well
they're going to be GI related like
nausea vomiting and erection they can
also report vision changes so if your
patient reports like double vision
blurred vision or especially that the
color of their vision like they're seen
yellowish greenish halos in their vision
that is a warning sign and it can also
cause cause dis arrhythmias which tends
to be a little bit later
now digoxin has a therapeutic range that
you need to remember so commit this to
memory that's another one of those
lovely test questions the range is 0.5
to 2 nanograms per milliliter anything
greater than 2 is considered toxic so
let's say you have a scenario and the
didge level is high what are you going
to do what's your nursing action you're
gonna hold the dose notify the MD now
what is the antidote for digoxin what
can reverse it it's easy to remember
it's called digibind now what can cause
digoxin toxicity
well electrolyte imbalances can
and this is another part that you
definitely want to remember a big
electrolyte imbalance that can cause
ditch toxicity is a low potassium level
called hypokalemia and this is where
that level drops less than 3.5 now
whatever a patient for a cardiac reason
especially like heart failure or
something like that where fluid is
backing up in the heart going to the
lung causing a lot of edema the patient
may also be on a diuretic to help remove
that extra fluid so if a patient is on a
diuretic you have to watch those ones
that wastes potassium through the urine
we're talking about like loop diuretics
specifically like furosemide lasix
that's a popular one because it can
lower the potassium level if they're on
digoxin as well they're at risk for
having a low potassium level so you want
to monitor that very closely other
electrolyte imbalances is like a low
magnesium level with hypomagnesemia and
this is a level less than 1.5 or a high
calcium level hypercalcemia and this is
where that level gets higher than 10.2
now which patients are at most risk for
digoxin toxicity because they have
altered liver and renal function usually
it's decrease well our elderly
population because these systems aren't
working as great as they should and this
is where this drug is really removed
from the body we have to watch them on
digoxin another big takeaway about the
responsibilities of a nurse is whenever
we're administering this medication we
want to measure the apical pulse if you
don't know how to do that I have a whole
video on how to do that and you're gonna
do this for one full minute and you will
hold the dose of didge if it is less
than sixty beats per minute in an adult
less than 70 beats per minute in a child
or less than 90 to 110 beats in an
infant
next is side-effects what other side
effects came this patient have with this
drug they can have fatigue
diarrhea or thrombocytopenia and then
the last part of our questions was
education pieces what are we going to
teach this patient who's going to be
taking digoxin well of course we want to
teach them how to recognize those signs
and symptoms of toxicity and especially
those early signs and symptoms that were
related to the GI system the nausea the
vomiting and anorexia also that they
need to keep their appointments for when
they need drug levels drawn or we're
going to monitor their electrolytes or
their liver or renal function and just
let the patient know that they're really
important to keep so we can make sure
they're not getting digoxin toxicity and
if they are on drugs that are wasting
the potassium like those diuretics the
importance of consuming foods that are
rich in potassium which would be like
potatoes port tomatoes oranges avocado
spinach bananas things like that to keep
that level high because remember
hypokalemia can cause digoxin toxicity
and how to measure their pulse how to
count their heart rate before they take
their drug every time and when to call
the doctor if their pulse rate is too
low and talked to them about those
parameters that we went over with this
drug okay so that wraps up this review
over digoxin thank you so much for
watching don't forget to take the free
quiz and to subscribe to our channel for
more videos